the gyro can experience cuz I don't
think we you know when you see a woman
you try to understand like what is
what's the world through her eyes right
you know you're never gonna feel the way
she feels I'm never gonna look at
somebody else and be like oh they can
kill me right now all the time you know
yeah that's who that's a huge part but I
mean even just interfacing with the
world through a different type of human
body a female human body versus a male
human body in terms of like estrogen and
the testosterone ratio and how your
maternal instincts and oxytocin and all
these different yeah heightened
sensitivity you know in certain
situations they have like superpowers
actually you describe it that way
they're making human yeah humans in
their body and they have to like make
sure that everyone's safe around them
because every now and then men will
murder them right yeah or yeah arepa
exactly
Jesus crazy sorry ladies sorry yeah
would you really think about it it's
like what am relationship it's mad the
relationship between males and females
yeah it's mad that's why I always laugh
at dudes who get you know when guys get
jacked for their divorce money I was
like oh come on you're gonna be alright
yeah you know all the terrible things
that could go wrong right that's just
you just get jacked for some money
I like that perspective actually I kind
of puts it on perspective you're just
like yeah that's how many raped and
killed Jesus you get look people get
into bad relationship I mean I'm not
happy that someone ever gets into a bad
relationship but if you get into a bad
relationship and it's she's just a gold
digger and it's one was wrong yeah like
I've had so many friends that have been
like yeah my [ __ ] ex-wife she wants
more money you gotta go to court like
yeah but you can't get your murdered
player it's like you [ __ ] up [ __ ] in a
married her
she didn't know him she know and she was
crazy would you rather murder raped
really yeah for sure you sure don't want
either one obviously if a guy rapes me
and I'm so alive then I get to murder
him oh you gotta think about that we
could do murder yes
no I don't get I don't get murdered I
just get ripped okay I'll wait but
there's like this is the trauma with
that though you know yeah it'll be
trauma it's not gonna enjoy it
yeah it's gonna be terrible yeah but um
it's better than being dead
okay not saying it's good no but no I
all right
but for me you as a man as a human I get
to go have a great then murdered
okay sure there you go John wick after
that a hundred percent yeah just so
everybody [ __ ] down 100 percent rape
me or I'll murder you yeah I have a new
goal in life but you gotta say goodbye
to everybody before you do it how
because you do doctor then you're like I
say a lot yeah it's not John wick John
wick just drives home yeah they arrest
you but dude [ __ ] - and then you kill
them and they go to you media I go hey
what happened I mean what does the cops
say just like dude he raped me though
you're just like yeah well there's a law
you can order a guy because he raped Oh
Jay says there were rules so you can't
you can't hardly say I'm just saying the
world can't murder that make a shirt I
wonder if like he would sue you right
because like there's people that if you
made a shirt like you made say you made
a Conor McGregor shirt and you had some
quotes on it you were selling it he
could like maybe sue you if you keep his
face off yeah or he'd come to your house
like a bunch of dudes like take all his
stuff back you have a picture of OJ's
face like lean ins that selfie camera it
just says her to the world yeah I mean
come on Twitter burst by the way
whatever name it what it was it's OJ's
world it's me Twitter world he do
everything [ __ ] once he did that
shirt would be big giant it's probably
being made right now there's nerds that
are listening to us right now that are
going they're just gonna hit pause right
now yeah and make sort of yeah you just
made a go Jay submerge hate to the world
oh just gonna get that money
money I was gonna go to abuse women good
and waiters waiters have been murdered
by boyfriends goddamn will have knife
too uh personal they never found that
knife they never found that knife yeah
who had that knife but I mean damn Oh
Jay damn Oh Jeff
[Applause]